the Seal of America's second largest
bank is preparing for a possible U.S
debt default this is a CNN story
Congress is once again bickering about
raising the debt ceiling the amount of
money the U.S government can borrow to
pay its bills on time and that means
that Corporate America has to be ready
for the worse the CEO Bank of America
America's second largest bank City hopes
lawmakers resolve their issues because
the market and economy loves stability
yet defaulting on the countries debt
remains a possibility that cannot be
ignored we have to be prepared for that
not only in the country but in other
countries around the world Bank of
America CEO Brian Moynihan said you hope
it doesn't happen but hope it's not a
strategy so you prepare for it U.S
treasury secretary Janet Yellen has
already warned Congress that the country
could default on its Financial
Obligations as soon as June if the debt
ceiling is not raised before then what
are the chances that the debt ceiling is
not going to be raised zero zero zero
yeah they do this every every time every
time it's the same conversation yeah
it's a kabuki dance there's no there's
no question about it but uh I still
think in the end though it is a chairman
Powell who's going to decide whether we
have a recession or not well chairman
Powell is going to decide yeah the FED
is going to decide and and what do you
think is going to happen right now
Goldman Sachs just lowered the odds of a
recession from what it was before to now
20 25 percent is 45 yeah from 35 to 25
this is an Insider story according to
Goldman Sachs the odds of U.S economy
slipping into recession has dropped from
35 to 25 over next to the upgrade and
forecast is due to the combination of a
certain job numbers and Improvement in
business sentiment a better than
expected 517 000 payrolls were added in
January which suggest hiring is
continuing despite Rising inflation uh
but other economists are more
pessimistic surveys by Bloomberg and
Wall Street Journal have found the
consensus view that there's a 65 chance
of a sharp and severe downturn and
downturn in the upcoming year what do
you think is going to happen first of
all I think these things are all
manipulated of course because I'm a
conspiracy theorist uh
I don't I don't know but you could tell
from the tone of
Biden's uh State of the Union speech
that he is hoping for a soft Landing a
recession would really be problematic if
in fact he gets to run for re-election
uh I don't know what's going to happen I
think the different I think the odds of
the recession are somewhere in between
in other words I'm not sure they're 65
percent but I'm also not sure they're 25
I think they're somewhere in the middle
25 you don't think is 25 you don't think
it's 65. so if you're a betting man
would you bet on it happening this year
where the announcement will be made U.S
goes into recession well first of all
they never announced it in fact they
even when you're in the recession they
deny that you're in a recession so it's
not like they make a formal announcement
but I do think you could have a a
substantial slowdown in the economy yes
more than what we've seen I definitely
agree on terms of that and obviously
unless they edit the definition for
recession well they did what the White
House did when it was two quarters of
negative growth they're like no no no we
didn't say that they changed the
Wikipedia definition they're like no no
we didn't that's look it up it's a new
thing like I'll give you an example
vaccination to me that that used to mean
that well you take this and you're in
fact you're protected from being
infected you can't be infected so this
can't be a vaccination then can it
because what do I need a booster for I
mean if I already had the vaccination
yeah three before boosters Roger you
can't say you don't trust science the
don't do that on the spot yeah yeah you
know doctor we respect Dr Pochi because
he is you tried the place it was such a
great conversation the other day where
this girl asks me a question she's
trying to give me we talk about the sun
yeah Alex she said why don't you try
psychedelics and she says you trust
science don't you and I said define
science and she couldn't even answer it
I said because the definition of science
has changed a lot the last three years
what is science to me science is debate
if we can no longer have a debate then
there is no such thing as science
anymore scientists can't sit there and
debate their issues on each side so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign